JETS IN THEIR 3-VICTORY
NHL GAME AND IF HE WERE TO GET
INTO A GAME IT WOULD BE
HANGS ON THERE.
MICKEY: WELL, IF YOU THINK THATG
BACK WITH IT.
NOW IT I OF THOSE
DIFFERENT ONES THAT BUFFALO HAS,
RASMUS DAHLIN, NOT CLOSE TO
ANYONE ELSE AND DOING AND YOU KW
THTH FOR THIS LINE,
BUZZING WHEN THEY HAVEM DOING SS
IT IS COLIN MILLER PLAY A LOT TR
WITH GUELPH AND O NIGHT.
KEN: THE RED WINGS ON THE POWER
PLAY WITHMIDDLE OF A CHANGE, THO
GET POSSESSION, CONTROL AND RUSD
HERE NOW IT COMES AROUND MIDDLET
FUMES, YOU KNOW THATHAT HE
HAS GOT A LITTLE BIT OF THAT IN
HIM, FOR
TERRIFIC ATTITUDE AND NOW
GAGNER, NO ONE IS
SEASON FOR HIM AND NINE PUCK AND
ASPLUND COULD NOT GET PAST
SEIDER AND LOW, BERTUZZI, BACK
IN FRONT
MICKEY: GOING DOWN LOW FOR THIS
POWER PLAY WHEN YOU HAVEZZI, RAG
HERE SCORING CHANCES
AND DETROIT MAYBE A DOZEN OR SO.
MICKEY: A VERY GOOD CHANCE THERE
FOR BUFFALO WOULD NEVER
STEER US WRONG.AND WE'RE UNDERWD
PERIOD AND RAYMOND, THERE IT IS!
FACE-OFF AND
SCRAMBLING, NOW TUCH IS THERE.
RASMUSSEN IN BRYSON, BRYSON NOW
BACK FOR COLIN MILLER.
OUOU
THERE, THEY GET A BIG ONE.
MICKEY: THAT WAS A GREAT
AND IT IS